[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
con el objetivo de desincentivar el
tránsito terrestre hacia Estados Unidos
y la entrada irregular por la frontera
Sur estadounidense los gobiernos de
Estados Unidos y México alcanzaron un
nuevo acuerdo migratorio que por un lado
entregará un permiso a 24.000
venezolanos pero devolverá a territorio
mexicano a quienes no cumplan con los
nuevos requisitos de ingreso pero no
todos podrán postular Manuela Cano no se
explica En qué consiste este acuerdo en
el siguiente informe
Estados Unidos y México acordaron un
nuevo plan para controlar los crecientes
flujos migratorios por su frontera común
como parte del trabajo del gobierno
biden Harris para construir un sistema
de inmigración justo ordenado y seguro
el departamento de seguridad nacional
anuncia acciones conjuntas con México
para reducir las llegadas a nuestra
frontera suroeste y crear un proceso más
ordenado y seguro para las personas que
huyen de la crisis económica y
humanitaria en Venezuela el acuerdo
contempla por un lado gestionar el
acceso de miles de migrantes venezolanos
a Estados Unidos vía aérea y de volver a
México a aquellos que pasen de forma
irregular a Estados Unidos
el programa establece unas condiciones
específicas para que los migrantes
venezolanos sean elegibles tener un
patrocinador en Estados Unidos que le
brinde apoyo financiero y de otro tipo
pasar rigurosos controles biométricos y
biográficos de seguridad nacional y
seguridad pública presentar certificados
de vacunas y otros requisitos de salud
pública pero deja fuera a quienes
cruzaron la frontera estadounidense de
forma irregular después del 12 de
octubre cruzaron y regularmente Panamá o
México luego de la misma fecha fueron
expulsados de Estados Unidos en los
últimos cinco años a quienes no cumplan
con los requerimientos de salud pública
o aquellos venezolanos que tengan
residencia permanente en otro país o
cuentan con doble nacionalidad el
anuncio llega en un momento en el que el
flujo migratorio desde Venezuela y otros
países latinoamericanos no se detienen
por eso además ha pedido del gobierno de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador Washington
proporcionará 75.000 visas tempo
adicionales e inmigrantes de diversos
orígenes para trabajos no agrícolas
20.000 de ellas serán para
centroamericanos y haitianos
las deportaciones de los migrantes que
no cumplen con los requisitos pedidos
por Estados Unidos ya comenzaron solo el
13 de octubre Un día después de la
entrada en vigor de este nuevo plan
migratorio unos 300 venezolanos fueron
expulsados según funcionarios
estadounidenses Ahora son más las
preguntas que las respuestas para ellos
Yo sé que hay mucha gente que ya entró
Pero hay mucha gente que también que amo
por fuera
yo digo que lo más lógico era que
hubiese dado un previo aviso por lo
menos decir para la fecha tal ya no ya
no hay paso
sin embargo la gente se viene todavía
viene de la selva pensando que se iba a
pasar si no fueran deportados que me
manden para Venezuela un avión yo
tuviera tranquilo en Venezuela ya que me
mande para Venezuela pero Nos soltaron
aquí en la frontera qué hacemos No
hayamos que hacer nos da miedo de
volvernos para allá que nos metan un
poco de año preso por estar insistiendo
entonces no sabemos que necesitamos
haber que van a hacer con nosotros y
otra de las grandes preguntas que deja
este acuerdo es Qué pasará con los
migrantes venezolanos que para el 12 de
octubre ya estaban en tránsito terrestre
por Sur o Centroamérica se lo
consultamos a adamy saxon de la oficina
para asuntos latinoamericanos de bola
no han llegado a Panamá a México a los
que llegan después Si llegan a la
frontera con Estados Unidos y buscan
entregarse a los oficiales de Estados
Unidos para pedir asilo van a ser
rechazados si llegan el paso en cuestión
de horas van a encontrarse en Ciudad
Juárez y llegan a McAllen Texas van a
encontrarse en Reynosa Diego Tijuana y
ahí van a tener que
subsistir no van a tener derecho a pedir
asilo en Estados Unidos
a muchos me imagino van a contratar a
coyotes para llevarlos al otro lado para
esquivar o evitar ser
capturado por la culpabilidad fronteriza
el principal argumento en contra es que
se está negando a la población
venezolana el derecho que existe en la
ley y la ley internacional de pedir
asilo o protección en Estados Unidos y
también quedan dudas sobre la postura
migratoria del gobierno de Joe biden ya
que si bien ha buscado eliminar el
título 42 implementado por la anterior
administración ahora se vale de las
deportaciones como medida de presión
para contener el flujo migratorio esto
nos dijo Adam al respecto
es una ironía bastante fea diría yo hoy
en día el departamento de Justicia del
gobierno está ante las Cortes federales
restando una demanda puesto por algunos
gobernadores de Estados Unidos
republicanos que está forzandole al
gobierno de mantener el título 42 el
gobierno de pan quiso acabar con título
42 a finales de mayo de este año
mientras las cortes para acabar el
título 42 están forzandole a México a
expandir el título 42 eso debilita
totalmente sus argumentos ante la Corte
Federal Aunque ahora no veo a nadie
hablando de ninguna justificación de
salud pública para mantener esa política
no parece no tener que nada que ver
ahora con con el kobies es algo que
realmente están usando como bloqueo a
los solicitantes de asilo
el plan migratorio sólo beneficiaría
24.000 venezolanos una cifra muy por
debajo de los datos de ingresos solo en
septiembre 33.000 migrantes de esa
nacionalidad llegaron a la frontera
estadounidense hasta que inmigrantes de
Francia 24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f-24 sigan con más información
en francés 24 y France 24.com
[Música]